humans can survive in this universe as
long as we have an energy source
unfortunately the universe will die it
will happen slowly over many billions of
years but it will happen
on a universal time scale stars like our
Sun will be gone in no time luckily
there are places that will exist
practically forever from a human
perspective the corpses of dead stars
white dwarfs they could be humanity's
last home right before the death of the
universe what are these strange things
and what happens when they finally die
[Music]
how long stars live varies drastically
depending on how massive they are for
example really massive stars burn hot
and fast dying violently in supernovae a
few million years after birth but
they're the exception 97% of all stars
will end their existence as white dwarfs
there are two ways this can happen small
stars so-called red dwarfs burn out over
trillions of years until they eventually
quietly turn into white dwarfs
medium-sized stars like our Sun are more
interesting imagine the Sun as a huge
pressure cooker that fuses hydrogen into
helium in its core through its gravity
the fusion of elements releases extreme
amounts of energy that pushes outwards
and stabilizes the star keeping it in a
delicate balance when the Sun is old the
hydrogen in the core is exhausted and
the Sun will begin to burn helium into
heavier elements while doing so it will
shed its outer layers when this process
is over more than half of the sun's mass
will be lost into space as a spectacular
planetary nebula millions of kilometers
across what remains will be its former
core
a white dwarf is born a star corpse
while its former self was about 100
times its diameter now it's only about
as big as Earth but still with about
half of its former mass this means it's
extremely dense a teaspoon of white
dwarf is about as massive as a car its
surface gravity is over 100 thousand
times higher than Earth if you tried to
land on it you'd immediately be
compressed into a steaming puddle life
around a white dwarf is very unlikely
but possible most of them that exist now
were former stars that well died which
probably ruined any planets they once
had but that's not all since they are so
small the planet would need to orbit
them about 75 times closer than Earth is
to the Sun to have liquid water this
proximity has up-and-down sides for one
it would tightly lock the planet giving
it a permanent day and permanent night
[Music]
and the edges of these day and night
zones life could be possible but white
dwarfs have a very stable energy output
so they might actually be safer to live
around than many red dwarfs this is
still speculation at this point but if
we could find a white dwarf with the
right conditions to settle around we
could have a home for many billions of
years but why do they shine so much
longer than other star types white
dwarfs are very very hot up to 40 times
hotter than our Sun ranking among the
hottest objects in the universe that
they are not incredibly active all the
heat inside of them is trapped and has
nowhere to go only on its outer layer
can it escape into space but space is
mostly empty so heat can't be
transferred by conduction the only way
energy can escape is by radiation
this is so inefficient that white dwarfs
will take trillions of years to cool
down which may make them humanity's last
refuge they might be the last sources of
light and energy in a dying universe
according to some estimates white dwarfs
might shine as long as 100 billion
billion years ten billion times longer
than the universe has existed so far
into the future that no regular stars
will shine any more galaxies will have
evaporated and only then will the first
white dwarf turn into the first black
dwarf when this happens the last hope
for life will die off black Dwarfs will
be inactive spheres with no energy left
to give still massive enough to kill you
if you get too close so cold that
they'll be near the coldest possible
temperature in the universe so dark that
they are practically invisible the
universe will enter its last stage heat
death which will leave the universe
unrecognizable an absolutely dark and
cold graveyard with black holes and
black dwarfs scattered over trillions of
light-years we don't know for sure what
will happen with black dwarfs in the end
if the proton one of the fundamental
parts of atoms has a limited lifespan
black Dwarfs will slowly evaporate over
many trillions of years if the proton
does not decay black dwarfs will
probably turn into spheres of pure iron
via quantum tunneling over a timespan so
obscenely gigantic that calling it
forever is okay these ions fares will
then travel completely alone through a
dark universe nothing new will happen
anymore forever while this may sound
kind of dark this is so far away that
for our purposes today it might as well
not happen at all it doesn't matter what
happens in a billion trillion years
right now we happen to exist at an
excellent time able to be in or about a
universe filled with endless stars and
light and planet
and enough time to visit them one day
our music is finally available on
Spotify in iTunes it's composed by our
good friends at Epic mountain two guys
with a studio who make music for a
living
you can check them out here and follow
them on Facebook and Twitter and if you
like our videos please consider
supporting us on patreon it really would
be extremely helpful if you need an
excuse to delay work a little bit longer
here's a playlist with more space videos
you